hey youtubers it's Charlie so this is
gonna be my Supergirl episode 7 video
big WTF reveal for the hank henshaw
character so just careful for spoilers
if you haven't seen it yet just because
I haven't been doing Supergirl videos
for every single episode this video is
gonna be a little bit different but you
get the idea just just explain the
really big reveal first the big thing
everyone's talking about is that Hank
Henshaw
on Supergirl turned out to secretly be
Jean Jones the Martian Manhunter from
the comics huge WTF I could not be
happier that the characters on the show
before we found out that's who he
secretly was I was actually a little
upset because I was like well if he's
gonna be Hank Henshaw then he could be a
cyborg Superman but if he's secretly
Martian Manhunter because of the Chloe
red eyes that we've seen the last couple
of weeks does that mean that there is no
real Hank Henshaw from the comics on the
TV show like are they saying that
character doesn't exist at all but the
really cool thing that the TV show did
that kind of made me breathe a sigh of
relief is say that Hank Henshaw died so
the way John Jones explains it is that
he was running from the real Hank
Henshaw in car and Alex's father they
were pursuing him just like they would
pursue other alien fugitives on the
planet like he says though Alex's father
played by Dean Cain realized that
Martian Manhunter was not a villain and
tried to help him but the real Hank
Henshaw was crazy he would not stop
until Martian Manhunter was under lock
and key during the pursuit Martian
Manhunter believed that Hank Henshaw and
dr. Danvers died now as he was dying he
made the promise to protect the earth as
well as protect Alex and Cara's secret
so he assumes the identity of Hank
Henshaw who's in charge of this
organization that tracks down alien
threats now that doesn't completely
explain why he's been such a to
Cara and Alex the reason the producers
explained he's been so short with Cara
specifically when she became Supergirl
is because he is afraid that she is
going to mess up his operation he feels
like he's using this organization to
keep the earth safe like he really is
trying to keep his say he doesn't want
the same thing to happen to the earth
that happened to his home planet of Mars
what happened to his home planet of Mars
though in case you haven't read the
comics there was this throwaway line in
the episode where Jem said that he's
going to hurt or kill all the loved ones
of Martian Manhunter and as he turns and
walks away he says there's no one left
to hurt
just implying that all of his family all
of his people are dead he believes
himself the last living survivor of Mars
now in the comics what happened to his
planet there been like a couple of
different versions of the character they
changed the continuity a little bit but
essentially his brother became this evil
figure in their society and created this
plague that led to the downfall of their
society Martian Manhunter was
inadvertently teleported to earth where
he was stranded now he did say he got
stranded on earth they changed the
reasoning for that the way that that
happens at various points in the comics
but essentially he gets teleported to
earth because of this science experiment
and gets stranded but he still believes
himself the last living survivor of Mars
the reason he's called Martian Manhunter
is because he was a Manhunter that was
his job when he was on Mars he was a
peacekeeper so now he's just continuing
his mission on his adopted planet of
Earth just the same way Superman would
but the reason he has a beef against
Superman on the TV show as well as Kara
now is because he feels like they're
causing too much trouble causing more
problems than they're solving so when he
tells Alex you can't tell Cara about
this you have to keep this secret from
her you know that anytime people within
a group keep secrets from each other it
always comes out blows up in their faces
but the reason he doesn't want Carr to
find out is because he is kind of amused
with her learning her powers figuring
out how to be a superhero so he actually
does want to help that along and he
feels like maybe coming out to her would
cause more problems than it would solve
so what I think is probably gonna end up
happening is is they'll push that to the
back half that'll be like a back half
reveal before the big big season finale
there's gonna be 20 episodes total so
sometime before episode 20 Karl will
find out that Martian Manhunter has been
living next to her this whole time think
of it as a twist from the flash season
one with the eobard thawne reveal the
villains been here the whole time
well the Martian Manhunter has been here
too the whole time now even if you
haven't read the comics you know that
Martian Manhunter can shape-shift but
he's also super strong he could fly and
he's telepathic now the producers did
explain that when he used his powers to
kill Jem in this episode who's actually
a big figure in the Martian Manhunter
mythos he had not used them for a long
time because he'd been trying to keep
such a low profile as the fake hank
henshaw so what I think might end up
happening is is that we'll see him use
his powers in minor ways like we've seen
him used the telepathy when he sends
that Alex was searching their database
when he told her
not to so he might continue to do that
use his powers in very subtle ways so
the people don't figure him out secrets
like that always come out so eventually
someone's gonna find out Maxwell Lord
really hates aliens doing things for
humans so if he were to find out that
Hank Henshaw was secretly martian
manhunter he would probably flip his
and just because i've seen a lot of
people in my Supergirl videos who have
absolutely no idea who Maxwell Lord is
from the comics I'm just gonna put off
talking about him in the comic books but
if you do know all about Maxwell Lords
relationship with the Justice League
then you know what might end up
happening when he finds out about
Martian Manhunter just to give a little
background though on them turning the
David Harewood actor into Martian
Manhunter they didn't start out wanting
to do that they said that they were
standing on the set of the pilot in like
all the big executive producers like
Geoff Johns the showrunners Andrew
Kreisberg from the flash they were all
standing there just kind of joking about
David Harewood the actor they were
saying that he kind of had these big
ears that looked a little alien like and
they were like well wouldn't it be funny
if he turned out to be Martian Manhunter
wouldn't it be cool if that character
was on TV and they credit Jeff Jones
with being the one that said why can't
we make him Martian Manhunter like why
don't we do that so after a bunch of
conversations with the network they
approached the David Harewood actor and
said look this is where we want to take
your character you were going to
secretly be this huge Justice League
member from the comics and the funny
thing is is that the actor David
Harewood was like oh my god
thank you this is so amazing I was
having such a hard time trying to figure
out the hank henshaw character the actor
was having a hard time trying to find an
angle to play him without making him
seem like a mustache twirling villain
and usually when you see him in the
comics he's already cyborg superman and
he's trying to find a way to die like he
can't die and that's all he wants to do
he just I want to end my existence he
even asks the anti-monitor at a certain
point to kill him because no one else
can so it's kind of one-dimensional it
doesn't really make for an awesome TV
character over a 20 episode season
so making a Martian Manhunter is just
way easier from a character standpoint
and way more fun now we can get into a
lot of the mythology of the Mars
backstory like with the white Martians
the green Martians along with Gem
Society now it seems like on the TV show
he killed gem the gem was a very
important figure amongst his people so
they might try to retaliate
in the same way that the Kryptonians now
that have escaped the Phantom Zone are
trying to take over the earth so just
one more big space threat that they
could bring into the mix on the show at
a certain point for now though the big
threat is Cara's aunt and those
Kryptonians that escape the Phantom Zone
so Martian Manhunter probably going to
be the only Martian on screen for a
little while
here's my big question for you guys so
first off what do you think about the
Martian Manhunter reveal I really did
like the scene where they gave it away
it seemed very touching like look I'm
not the enemy
I'm actually here to protect you I made
your father a promise I'm just
pretending to be an because I
want everyone to be safe and to second
big question do you think that the real
Hank Henshaw will come back as cyborg
Superman at a certain point here's my
thoughts on that why would they use the
hank henshaw name if this person was
secretly going to be Martian Manhunter
they could have used any kind of fake
name generator for this character and
then at some later point in the series
actually brought Hank Henshaw on the
show is like a villain of the week or
something like that
my thoughts are that they chose the name
because they want to use him on the show
in a big way but they want to tease it
out like they very clearly did not know
that he was going to be Martian
Manhunter when they started writing the
show that that only developed over time
but I think that they're gonna trying to
spin it out into something a little bit
more fun like oh my god he's not dead
and he's a cyborg now that we have
trouble killing Jon Jones did say the
real Hank Henshaw was batshit crazy
so that just feels like I'm laying the
foundation for a big villain arc
sometime later in the series maybe not
even in season one maybe season two if
you guys want to read some really
awesome comic book arcs for Martian
Manhunter read brightest a really
awesome storyline for him others among
us as in there are other Martians among
us and then Jael a trial by fire gets
into the mythology of Martians being
afraid of fire all I can say is that I'm
hoping for some sort of Oreo integration
on the TV show
Oreos a big brand I feel like they'd be
happy to have Supergirl teach Martian
Manhunter how to double stack his Oreos
arrow and the flash actually did an ad
for Guitar Hero earlier this year you
know they did like that guitar
competition that was a straight-up ad I
would be so happy if Supergirl did like
an Oreo version of that with Martian
Manhunter later this season really big
news later tonight though is that the
flash midseason finale is happening zoom
is totally gonna come and ruin Christmas
for Team flash the tricksters coming
back Mark Hamill is
leading this really awesome rose revenge
storyline be sure to subscribe to get my
video I'll post it right after the
episode airs in great Berlin see
actually did respond to the rumor about
the flash Supergirl crossover later this
year
he said that they just got picked up for
the back half Supergirl did so they're
gonna deal with that first but they
hadn't really started talking about an
actual crossover yet he didn't say it
would never happen he just said that
they haven't started talking about it
yet so while you guys wait for the flash
tonight you can click here for the
trailer with Mark Hamill it's gonna be
so much fun seriously watch the flash
tonight and you can click here for the
Star Wars behind the scenes video that I
just posted thank you so much watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight